also wie ich gratuliere nochmal zur
schwangerschaft und wünsche euch
natürlich alles gute
[Musik]
hey leute was geht ab bereits willkommen
bei einem neuen video ja leute ich hoffe
euch geht's gut ich bin gerade
aufgestanden und habe ich mir für heute
vorgenommen dieses video jetzt zu drehen
einfach weil ich finde dass es jetzt
alter was geht heute morgen ab heute wo
soll ich anfangen ich bin eher gerade in
griechenland und wir sind am sonntag
hier hingeflogen genau und am letzten
freitag oder am letzten donnerstag habe
ich diese keine analyse von dem baby
video gemacht warum ich gedacht habe
dass es sich bei diesen ganzen kurzen
videoclips die sie halt hochgeladen hat
nicht um irgendeine schwangerschaft
dreht sondern um irgendwelche produkte
die halten herausgebracht werden
und ich war mir halt wirklich zu 100
prozent sicher dass ich da wird recht
hat und wurde dann im endeffekt wirklich
also also man kann ja schon sagen ich
bin richtig krass ins fettnäpfchen
getreten das sagt man ja so also ich
wurde ja brutal hoch genommen indem man
halt glaube ich am samstag oder sonntag
dieses video kamen baby dann gesagt hat
dass sie schwanger ist und ich habe mir
das an grippe und ich dachte mir in dem
moment
alex du läufst komplett falsch und jetzt
bin ich mal auf den hält gespannt auf
dieses video folgt es ging aber sogar
ich würde sagen wir schauen uns das
einfach mal zusammen an moment so ich
habe gerade hier nach klippenspringen
gesucht weil ich immer sehr gerne von
klippenspringer allerdings so wenn das
wasser tief genug ist das muss man
vorher natürlich schaut aber wir schauen
jetzt einfach mal nach diesem video
und genau hier ist es das video hat
jetzt 411.000 views hat sogar 10.900
likes und 3400 discs was jetzt natürlich
mal sind schon viele dislike und 6000
kommentare und mein angepinnt kommentar
hat wer einem besen zu viel hat fast
4000 likes also ich habe ja in einem
video gesagt wenn sie wirklich schwanger
ist fresse ich einen besen einfach weil
ich mir so sicher war dass sie nicht
schwanger sein kann es gab ja so viele
videos dazu wo leute gesagt haben ja wo
sie stoppt das so und so analysiert und
ich wollte all diesen leuten zeigen ich
weiß ist dass sie nicht schwanger ist
und ist halt komplett nach hinten
losgegangen ist eine fliege auf der
kamera
also ich muss an dieser stelle sagen ich
hätte es wirklich nicht gedacht aber
glückwunsch auch von meiner seite ich
glaube das ist so fasst ja ich kann mich
jetzt nicht daran erinnern dass
irgendeine große youtube plötzlich
schwanger war also eine ganz große
youtube rinnen und babys war die größte
in deutschland und wenn man sich durch
liest du bist so ein opfer die as the
prices schwanger ich würde vielleicht
erst mal nachdenken bevor man falsche
gerüchte in die welt setzt also viel
spaß beim essen natürlich ist das blöd
gewesen von mir aber das würde ich jetzt
auch nicht unbedingt so sagen mit
falsche gerüchte in die welt setzen
ich war mir halt wirklich aufgrund
dieser tatsache so sicher dass man ja
eigentlich keine promo aktion daraus
machen sollte wenn man schwanger ist
dass sich auch immer noch so als hätte
sie jetzt einfach in einem video gesagt
ja ich bin schwanger finde ich total
cool und aber dann halt auch so zwei
promo videos zu machen um halt dann im
dritten video zu sagen dass man
schwanger ist ob man das jetzt wirklich
machen muss kann man jetzt
wahrscheinlich unterschiedlich sehen
aber das war für mich halt dann mal so
eine sache man sagen könnte er stoppt
hier mache ich jetzt keine probe raus
das ist ein kind und da freue ich mich
drüber aber ich habe das halt so gesehen
und das sich halt immer noch so dass man
daraus keine promo aktion machen sollte
trotzdem natürlich alles gute ich freue
mich sehr für sie
und jetzt muss ich natürlich irgendwie
auch entgegenkommen weil ich habe so
viele nachrichten bekommen wirklich auf
instagram und instagram ist komplett
explodiert ich habe fast in jeder
sekunde eine nachricht bekommen du musst
jetzt ein besen essen und und ich habe
das gefühl das wird mich noch eine weile
verfolgen wenn ich es jetzt nicht mache
deswegen habe ich mir was überlegt ich
war gestern ein bisschen hier auf der
insel unterwegs ich kann euch mal zeigen
wo ich ungefähr war und zwar war ich da
ganz hinten
es geht also um die ecke und dann so ein
bisschen nach recht man denkt das gar
nicht aber auf einer insel einen besen
her zu bekommen wo man nur die sprache
kennt und auch alles auf griechisch
irgendwo steht das war sooo schwer aber
ich habe einen besen gefunden
moment ich zeige ihnen euch mal kurz
ja leute das ist der besen hat sechs
euro gekostet war glaube ich sogar ein
bisschen runter gesetzt wir haben hier
einmal den stil moment aber wir haben ja
einmal den besenstiel und dann dieses
dingen fähig super ich hab schon
getestet und wahrscheinlich will mich
jetzt jeder meiner freunde für komplett
bescheuert halten weil ich vorhabe besen
zu probieren
also es ist ja klar ich kann ihn ja
nicht ganz essen und ich habe mich auch
ein bisschen schlau gemacht das ist
natürlich auch schädlich holz zu essen
oder was auch immer hier von ich kann
euch das gerne mal kurz zeigen
ich habe eigentlich nach einem wesen
gesucht der aus schokolade ist gab es
leider nicht ist ja auch klar wer sollte
den besen aus schokolade herstellen oder
vielleicht aus einem wesen der unten so
wie heute dann hat das gibt es ja auch
damit ich das heuer ersten kann weil das
ist nicht so schädlich aber habe ich
nicht gefunden also wir sind gerade auf
google an dieser stelle auch ganz
wichtig an euch leute macht das nicht
nach vor allem an die jüngeren von euch
ja geht nicht zu ihren eltern und sagt
alex hat in weesen gegessen er hat
gesagt das geht das geht nämlich
eigentlich nicht lass das ist schädlich
und ja das ist ganz wichtig ich habe mir
nämlich gestern schon gegoogelt und zwar
habe ich hier diese gutefrage.net seite
gefunden
da geht es einfach darum hier da fragt
der kinkel affen
ich esse gerne holz ich habe gerade den
ganzen stil eines eis am stiel gegessen
ist das gesundheitsschädlich oder gesund
ich habe mir da vorher gedacht wenn du
so holz ist das ist halt wir müssen sich
das so vorstellen unser körper kann ja
eigentlich vieles verdauen nur holz ist
halt irgendwie schwer zu verdauen weil
ja die nährstoffe dir drin sind die kann
unser körper halt einfach nicht
aufnehmen das holz ist für den menschen
körper unverdaulich also eher
ballaststoff aber schädlich ist es
glaube ich nicht trotzdem möchte ich
ungerne jetzt holz essen einfach weil
ich angst habe das natürlich so splitter
sich auch im magen verfangen können oder
so und das wollen wir natürlich nicht
wenn du keine splitter mehr im mund
fühlst nimmst du auch keinen schaden
gesundheits völlig ist das nicht aber
auch nicht schlimm zähne weg von
behandeltem holz guten politik so ich
hoffe natürlich ihr versteht das dass
ich das nicht von dem holzfass essen
kann trotzdem
muss ich das auch einfach mal fair sein
und sagen weil ich so ein idiot war
unserem video gemacht habt wo ich so
sicher von irgendwas anderem war da
irgendwas falsches behauptet habe was
natürlich nicht fair ist und das muss
ich auch ganz eindeutig einsehen hab ich
mir jetzt vielleicht man kann es als
kleine bestrafung sehen wie bei einer
challenge an dem ding sind ja diese
borsten und diesem so aus stoff
wahrscheinlich jetzt brauchen ab machte
mir auf meinem teller brötchen und dann
hätte ich oder irgendwie so keine ahnung
also nochmal ganz wichtig macht es nicht
nach und nein ich esse kein holz so
leute also kommt man mit drei so jetzt
habe ich das nicht angekommen
im kühlschrank haben wir daraus gezogen
einfach eine extrem laut ist gut wir
haben ein tor vor und lud eller und
wir in weesen und hiervon mache ich
jetzt ein paar teile ab wie findest du
die idee gut werden würde
das ist ein kleines kleines gewürz auch
dass nutella brötchen unterschätzt und
guck mal hier
so leuchtet wenn man das jetzt hier
leicht verteilt also ich würde sagen ein
bisschen geht auf jeden fall noch
deswegen so und das hier noch man sieht
es zu viel von dem stoff ist natürlich
auch nicht gesund und nicht verträglich
deswegen also wer möchte ich einige
gewürze drauf und um das jetzt noch ein
bisschen besser zu machen gibt es das
wort machen wir einfach mal ein bisschen
nutella drauf auf einer skala von eins
bis zehn wie du findest du in dieser
aktion und sehen so dass er den leuten
gehen so damit jetzt auch keiner sagt
dass es fake sieht man hier die ganzen
wesen sieht man das auf der kamera hier
zum beispiel seht ihr die besen stütze
und ich würde sagen wir gehen als
einfach raus damit zufällig noch was
retten das mit einem besuch
also wie ich gratuliere nochmal zur
schwangerschaft und wünsche euch
natürlich alles gute und jetzt ist er
erlegt ein leben lang sogar auf dieser
seite hier an
das ding ist alex auch noch schwer jetzt
das so zu essen weil er sonst auch immer
sein frühstück noch nicht mehr aufs geld
und ich muss sagen
man merkt schon wie sich diese wesen
fasern so in die zähne aber ein bisschen
so als wenn der zahnbürste sodinger
abgehen oder
[Musik]
lecker also leute an dieser stelle noch
mal wenn ich zu hause nachmachen sondern
ist ein paar besen bürsten mit drauf ich
hoffe das video hat euch unterhalten
youtube deutschland 2018 alex ist ein
wesen und wir sehen uns beim nächsten
video last nach oben da wollten wir gern
auf instagram und snapshot und wir sehen
uns dann morgen oder übermorgen wieder
hart rein
schöne grüße auch an meinen eltern das
einen warmen geschrieben hat ja dass ich
ein besserer smartphone holen soll
haut rein